right
left left oh I'm okay wait you can't
even blame me for this because I'm
literally you going ask any of my
friends any of my family I am notorious
for being bad of my left and right she's
playing the fucking game she
knows can you stand back behind your
vehicle please you please just go back
over to your just stand behind your
vehicle so I was going to robbery with
the rest of you guys mhm um two cars
turned from Northbound on Seven Springs
McMullen Booth they were north of me so
I made I was stopped at the like getting
ready to make a right turn so they
turned in front of me there was a
Mustang I thought it was a Mustang in
front of behind this car I was in the
left hand lane um really didn't see any
driving until the Mustang turned got in
front of me
then passed this car and got back in the
right hand lane and when that happened
we were coming up to Pine Ranch she
almost sideswiped and I'm like oh and so
I pulled up beside her to take a look in
the and she wouldn't look she just kept
looking at the uh Straight Ahead then
all of a sudden we went from 35 40 mph
to 75 she took off she to avoid the
Mustang she drove up by this
uh storage facil
drove up on the grassy shoulder and then
of course the Mustang took off so I said
were you following the Mustang she said
it's kind of sort of so she's she has a
valid license comes back to I'm assuming
her father the car she said she's coming
from an AA meeting and she's coming to
her sister's house who lives off of
Wayne wri I'm not sure if Wayne wri's
here um blood bloodshot glassy eyes slur
speeds a not of now like beverage so I
asked her to give me her driver's
license she gave me her AAA card um I
asked her for a registration she bends
over to the glove box takes
a um envelope WIP envelope out of the
and it's soaking wet so I said did you
throw a drink in there she says no I
said have you been drinking she says no
said have you had anything to drink she
said no as far as alcohol um and I said
okay um I asked her to stay in the car
she's gotten out a couple times I heard
her rumaging for something her on the
passenger front seat her purse looked
like it was dumped out
so that's where
we hello okay hi hi I'm Deputy phoh
what's going on tonight I literally came
home for my boyfriend's birthday party I
wanted to tell my sister I was sober cuz
I was proud of how many days I'd come
with AA and I I was she was so mad at me
cuz I text her back throughout the whole
party and so I told her I will literally
come to you prepis so where I was
balling my eyes out because she didn't
believe me and she was so mad at me but
she also suffers from like bipolar
disorder so I was like I'm going to
prove to you I'm sober in a way but I
was so upset about it I'm so sorry okay
so you didn't have anything to drink
tonight no sir okay I can do a test for
you I can do anything okay so how come
your you normally slow your words no sir
okay what's causing that right now I'm
not sling my words yeah you are I can
that's is that how you speak normally
the way you're talking right now
typically okay are your eyes normally
bloodshot and glassy and watery I've
been soling my eyes out for like 30
minutes would you like me to follow a
light or do any test for you okay I'll
have you do that in just a second but I
just want to make sure are you not
having like a medical uh medical
condition right now are you you don't
need an ambulance don't need fire rescue
or nothing like that okay all right how
come we can smell alcohol you smell
alcohol yeah no
no okay what are the cans that are
underneath your seat that you were
trying to kick
back um they're of alcohol that I bought
from my friends at the
party okay how' they make it in your
vehicle because I bought
them okay so you bought them they drank
them and you then put them back in your
vehicle no no no what happened was I put
them into a
into like a I don't know what to call
like a container where everyone I drink
it it's called Jungle Juice where
everyone makes like a big concoction of
alcohol okay so but that that doesn't
make any how did how did they end up
under your driver's seat was I put them
there because you had pull me
over okay so you like we got nervous
that we were going to see them so you
put them there yes okay so what are the
cans of what kind of alcohol white claws
okay but you didn't drink any of them
tonight no I have but like earlier how
many did you have tonight I only had two
okay how long ago uh 2 hours 2 hours ago
right okay how come you didn't tell me
that when I first asked you because
you're you're a cop okay I know but the
but honesty is the best thing with us
okay I know but like if you lie to me
then that means anything else you tell
me now I'm not going to believe you but
you're am I that scary I feel like I've
been talking to you pretty uh pretty
nice no we like a full unicorn and like
you're scary all right appearing do you
feel that you are under the influence of
alcohol right now I feel like I'm fine
okay I could do any test for you all
right I appreciate that all right you
want to step outside and I'll check your
eyes real quick okay you want to step
here behind your
vehicle
hold you wearing contacts or anything
yes sir no okay all right place your
feet together just like me oh you can
take a step back place your feet
together hands down by your side just
like this okay what color is this red
all right what I want you to do is I
want you to follow this light with your
eyes and your eyes only do not move your
head okay do you understand that yes sir
all
right no keep your head straight just
follow with your eyes okay
okay we're going to go real slow just
continue to follow okay keep your hands
down by your side for
me all right we're going to do one more
we're going to go up this time
okay keep
[Music]
following what's the
problem what's up I said I'm so sorry
I'm literally going
shooting okay you I was here for the
weekend for my previous a birthday all
right that's okay like I said I'm just
trying to make sure that it's that
you're safe to be driving right now
that's all okay all right I'm going to
go up on this one okay just continue to
follow keep your head straight remember
what I told you the first time right cuz
you you originally told me you didn't
have anything to drink then you said you
had two white claws right I told you I
told I know I know I know listen like I
told you honesty is the best policy
right now okay so I need you to be
completely honest with you cuz I can
already tell that you're lying still how
much did you have to drink had that how
much did you drink I only had two EGS
okay I need earlier today because I had
Mythic exam okay all right are you
willing to do some more field sobriety
exercises yes all right
perfect I just got to ask you some
questions before we do this okay
okay are you sick or injured no are you
diabetic well okay wait sorry when we
say sick or injured I mean I have had Co
the past week this past week
I was confirmed that I had been exposed
on Thursday of last week Thursday of
last week okay but are you currently
sick or injured stuie knows I've been
taking like cold and allergy medication
every day okay when did you say you were
you were exposed last Thursday last
Thursday have you gotten tested no sir
all right just H TI one sec
okay I'll be right back okay I'll be
there in just a second
this the heads up if I go 10 I'm going
to have to go medical clearance told me
that she got exposed to co last
Thursday did she test she hasn't tested
she hasn't tested but I know that one of
the uh the questions they ask you on
your pre uh on your form when you get to
the jail or Pat is have you been exposed
in the last two weeks and she answers
yes so we're going to have to
transporter ourselves where I'll have to
take her to I'll have to take her to the
I'll have to take her to get medical
clearance so is she she has s been she's
not showing any symptoms of Co yeah no
nothing that I can see she said she
takes fold and flu medication but she
hasn't she doesn't have any symptoms but
the jail if she if she answers on that
questionnaire that she was exposed last
Thursday then they're going to make me
take her get medical
clearance so just a heads up on that all
right let me let me just make sure with
her real real fast cuz I know you said
that you got exposed last week do you
have any uh symptoms
currently um no taste no
smell not really coffee anymore see
using you have all of that you're saying
yes you have you do have a taste or you
don't have taste I do not have taste or
smell and what about the cough you said
you do have a cough or you don't I did B
didn't anymore how long ago did you not
have it yesterday
today she's playing the fucking V she
know I can you stand back behind your
vehicle please please just go back over
to your just stand behind your
vehicle do the investigation and we'll
deal with u cuz she has she's going to
have to go out there to
get and right well I can do that at dist
one I just know that um if you want to
call if you want to call the jail and
find out what their procedures are all
right let me do that real quick hey
minut hey so I got a girl out here who's
playing the fucking game she's saying
that she got exposed to co last week um
last Thursday she's she doesn't she's
not exhibiting any current symptoms but
she's telling me Oh I got the loss of
taste and smell I had a cough yesterday
and all this
bullshit um what what's your guys
procedure on that okay so I so I don't
have to take her so I don't have to take
her to get fucking medical cleed or
anything I mean yeah like she's not
exhibiting any signs it's signal one and
she's just playing the fucking game or
it's it's D
it's going to be DUI
yeah okay sounds good all appreciate it
man thank you y see
you all right I can do a walk test for
you y That's I was going to have you do
that next yep I was going to do that
next all right I appreciate it all you
want to step over here I'll explain the
instructions
okay we all right go ahead and stand uh
with your back to my corporal's vehicle
right here okay okay all right pick pick
a line okay I'll Pi this one all right
Perfect all right start with your left
foot on the line your right foot on the
nope left foot on the
line put your right foot in front of
your left foot touching heel the toe on
the line okay all right try to step away
from the vehicle if you can okay take my
shoes off yeah you yeah you can take
your shoes
[Music]
[Applause]
off all right try to step away from the
vehicle you can okay thank you all right
place your hands down by your side
remain in this position till we till I
tell you otherwise okay all right when I
tell you to begin but not before I tell
you I want you to take nine Heel To Toe
steps down the line okay as you're
taking those steps you're going to look
down at your foot and you're going to
count each step out loud it's going to
look just like this okay look at
me one 2 3 and you're going to go all
the way to nine okay on the ninth step
you're going to turn around by leaving
your left foot on the line and you're
going to turn around using a Ser by
pivoting on that left foot using a
series of small steps nope look at me
I'm going to show you okay pivot on that
left foot just like
this then you're going to start in the
same position and you're going to take
nine more steps one two 3 all the way
back down to nine okay all right do you
understand those instructions yes sir
all right go back into the position I
told you
about all right keep your nope don't
start yet don't start
yet all right place your hands down by
your side like I told
you all right and you can begin yeah
when you're ready
2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 and then this foot do the
three turn R
mhm
sorry 1 2 3 4
five 6 7 8
N9 all
right NOP that's okay all we're going to
do a couple more okay okay all right for
this next one I want you to start out in
that same position of the first one okay
feet together hands down by your side
okay when I tell you to you're going to
raise either foot of your choosing
approximately 6 in off the ground
approximately the size of a Coke can all
right I'm I'm going to raise my right
foot you can raise whichever foot you
choose okay I'm going to
demonstrate you're going to raise it
about this high you're going to keep
your leg extended your toe pointed
outwards you're going to stare down at
your extended foot and you're going to
count out loud in the following manner
1,1 1,2 13 1,4 and so on until I tell
you to stop I don't want you to put your
foot down listen I don't want you to put
your foot down but if you do just pick
it right back up and continue where you
left off
do you
understand do you understand my
instructions sorry
okay I'm so sorry all
right okay are you ready not
yet all right are you ready yes sir all
right place your hands down back down by
your side hold on don't start yet I
didn't tell you to start yet sorry are
you ready yes sir all right you can be
begin 1001 1002 13 1004 1005
1789 1220
122122 1223
all right I'm so sorry I can really do
it
I because I want to go that's all right
all right can I redo that no that's okay
I can do a lot better that's all right I
know I can okay that's okay I have one
more for you okay okay well was that
enough what's that I got I got one more
to do for you okay okay all right same
position feet together hands down by
your side all right can you show me your
index
finger all right perfect I want you to
point both your index fingers out just
like this okay can you show me your
right hand Perfect all right go back
down into the position with your fingers
pointed outward just like that when I
tell you to begin but not before you're
going to tilt your head back no keep
looking at me you're going to tilt your
head back and you're going to close your
eyes I'm going to call out either left
or
[Music]
right I'm going to call out I need to
finish explaining okay I'm going to call
out either left or right you're going to
raise the hand that I call out and
you're going to touch that finger to the
tip of your nose look at me so if I call
out right you're going to raise your
right hand your right finger look at me
you're going to touch the tip of your
finger to the tip of your nose okay as
soon as you touch the tip of your finger
to the tip of your nose immediately
bring that hand back down to your side
all right do you understand my
instructions sure okay go ahead and tilt
your head back close your
eyes
right
left
left left oh I'm okay wait you guys
can't even blame me for this because I'm
literally you ask any of my friends any
of my family I am notorious for being
bad of my left and right like they'll
ask me to do navigation and I'm always
pick last to do it because I am very bad
at it okay that's all right and and I
don't want you to judge all of this on
that okay that's all right
right all right do one more okay go and
take a a couple steps
forward all right do you know your
alphabet yes sir okay go Ahad and close
your eyes you know it from you know from
A to Z in that order okay that's right
you know from A to Z in alphabetical
order okay what I want you to do is when
I tell you to begin you're going to
close your eyes and and you're going to
recite from the letter e to the letter V
do you understand yes sir all right go
and begin e f g h i j k l l o p q r s t
u
v no
way are you kidding
stop despite her assertion of being
symptomatic for covid-19
the officer strictly adhered to
protective protocols and proceeded with
her arrest she was then transported to
the local station for further evaluation
and a breathalyzer
test I won't make a mistake get her
shoes
on yeah really guys I want can you guys
like explain like what's happening right
now you're being placed under arrest for
DUI okay and then what DUI for what for
driving under the influence of Al and
then what and then will like you at
least like test me more like do what
yeah so my next question for you okay is
are you willing to give a breath sample
sure
perfect I got to put this on you okay
okay all right go and put your uh your
shoes
on you have someone you can call to come
pick up your dad's car
no yeah we could tell it no no no let me
call my mom let me call my mom please
you said no let me call my mom at least
please please guys please like what can
I do no no your sweater pocket I have
nothing can I please do anything for you
please yeah we're going to go do the
breath test okay like I'm going to watch
watch he off of me
really how do you open your phone you
need a face ID or something
it's it's one of the oldest
time it's hard it's don't even worry
about it you have a phone number yep all
right what's your what's your parents
phone number let me get my phone don't
worry about
it no no all right then we're going to
have to impound your dad's car you
understand that we're trying to do
something nice to you and get someone to
come get it well guys please like I'm
want to go to bed okay well can I do for
you what can I do for you please listen
let's get beyond that okay it's time to
grow up time to deal with the situation
no no no let's get your dad's phone
number so he can come and get your car
and you're not in that much more trouble
so I'm sure your dad's not going to be
happy with the
issu right you know your mom's phone
number can I talk to you guys you know
your mom's phone number I'm going to ask
you one more time you do know it all
right
why am my ear let me talk to you we
we've done plenty of talking let me do
more talking to you then okay no we're
going to go to we're going to go no you
listen to me I willon get in your car
and you don't have to grab me well if
you're going to stop doing what you're
doing then I am going to grab you talk
to
me
pass great that's great all right do you
have anything on you right now any
weapons drugs needles nothing like that
nothing that's going to stick me poke me
or hurt me right nothing that would hurt
you or
anything please please wait can I talk
to you can I talk to you what do you
want to say no like I don't need this to
happen Okay well you didn't need to
drive drunk I didn't drive drunk is what
I'm telling you I can see I can't let's
go come on don't you want do you want to
get a charge with resisting arrest you
want to get charg with resisting then
get in the vehicle I'll get in the
vehicle but like you're going to go
through a breath test see how it goes
from there what's your you like a human
being what's your mom's phone number we
write the
voicemail
please please dear
Lord she's pissing me off I'm good with
Towing it anyway yeah no please I don't
mean to piss you off at all back in the
car and please do not talk your feet
back in the vehicle I hope you realize
this all oh my fucking god